hi I'm here with Caitlin today huh and
she's a fan of The Hobbit the movie I
was not a fan of the movie The Hobbit I
thought it sucked really bad I'm sorry
you're you're a loser so today we're
going to watch The Hobbit desolation of
smaug trailer yaks Peter Jackson wanted
to extend a short book into three movies
that's really cool potatoes and songs oh
that's a t-shirt
of your enormous e o Smaug the
stupendous yeah it's good month
everything's coming under to reclaim our
homeland I offer you my hem is AMA
sexual the trash it's all about thorin
oakenshield did it looks shot better
take me I've been down you're good
that's pretty tight I don't know I
followed the constant close-ups yeah
he's back
whoo look about sexy man not give him
hope where there is none
sorry ma was always back he looks like
our Lana blue we've been blond too you
can whine in our blindness again those
bags kicking ass yeah it's tiny ants
lord of the rings' see that I see that
do fun
mycology
good you're needed my Oh spiders
it's looks way better than the first one
I think the first one was just a setup
damn oh no no risk this quest for the
life of one buck is named miss pilbow
oh damn that's pretty scary no it's
better to come to that strip is it
really
now are they gonna do this in 3d yeah
they're both okay then the close-ups
make sense but yeah but that movie looks
way better than the first one
it had to be we were setting up all your
character pot lines so we can watch them
grow yeah it looks really exciting I'm
excited to see it I can't wait
uh-huh we're done